here's an important story from New York
Post says sorry love birds failing this
exam could mean your relationship is
flocked
up it's a New York Post uh hopeful
Honeys are putting perspective Partners
to a viral test praying that their
sweeties pass I can't even read this
article why I can't read it and I want
it because it's such an important
story praying their sweeties pass with
flying colors and if they don't that
means it's time to fly the
coupe
J Z wingwoman AL I can't read it I I
can't read it I can't read the story I
just can't I can't like why this is not
journalism I look I understand it's an
article about a Tik Tok Trend and so you
might think if this is not a time for
serious journalism but I how do you put
this is supposed to be a news article
and they put like seven bird puns into
the first two
sentences I can't get past it anyway the
point is that there's this new uh Trend
that apparent is very popular it's
called the bird test I think we have a
video of someone yeah we have a video of
someone on Tik Tok explaining what the
it's a relationship this is relationship
advice we always get good relationship
advice from Tik Tok so here's the the
trend here's the What's called the bird
test let's listen apparently a lot of
people don't know what the bird test is
which I'm sure there's like a better
name for it but that's wild to me
because I live and die by the bird
[Music]
test research has shown the single
biggest determining factor in whether a
happy relationship will last when one
partner says oh that's a beautiful bird
outside does the other partner respond
with something like wow that is
beautiful or do they blow their partner
off and ignore the
[Music]
bird is that a
woodpecker
what new pass
fast what that means we're going to be
in love forever
[Music]
ever all
right so that's the bird test uh the
bird test basically for for what I
gather is if you uh tell if you're in a
relationship and you tell
um your you know this is most mostly
women who are doing this obviously if
you tell your boyfriend or husband that
there's a bird outside and they go and
they want to go look at the bird then
that means that they are
taking then they pass the test because
they they're they are taking an interest
in the thing that you are interested in
and um if they don't then they fail the
test that's the bird test so you go to
your significant other and you say
there's a bird and if they if they jump
out of their seat and run let me go see
the bird where's the bird then they pass
the test and that means you should stay
in the relationship
a few problems with this first of
all I would fail the bird test in a
second and I've been married for 12
years so very you know very successfully
married I would fail the bird test um if
I'm if I'm like in the other room and my
wife yells hey come here and look at
this
bird I'm gonna say can you take a
picture or something and send it to me
why am I getting out of my chair to go
look at a bird like why am I why would I
even look over it better if I am making
any physical effort to go look at a bird
it damn well better be an impressive
freaking bird I mean this better be
there better be an ostrich in the front
yard if you're if you're bringing
attention to a bird it better be like a
a I don't know a penguin fighting a bald
eagle if if if you're making that big of
a deal about it if you didn't know
already Pure Talk is planning to
alleviate $10 million in veteran debt by
Veterans Day they'll get there by giving
a portion of every new order to this
cause with just one week to go Pure Talk
is 90% of the way there but they still
need your support think about this the
US military is made up of 100%
volunteers these are men and women who
willingly sacrifice everything they have
for this country when they're done
serving they return home to a tight job
market outrageous living expenses that's
why I'm so happy a private company like
pure talk has jumped in to help when you
switch to Pure Talk's Lightning Fast 5G
Network they'll donate a portion of
every new order to this noble cause you
can make a real difference just by
choosing Superior cell phone service
pure talks plan started just 20 bucks a
month offering unlimited talk text more
data and a mobile hotspot just go to Pur
talk.com / Walsh and make the switch
let's rally together and show unwavering
support for our veterans visit Pur
talk.com Walsh and switch to Pur talk
today it's the right move and it's the
American way that's Pur talk.com
walshay a woodpecker who cares about
woodpeckers but you know the main
problem with the bird test is that it is
a test okay and this is and this is so
much of the relationship advice you get
out there it's like stuff like even if
it's it's not the bird test it's a
little test well if you do this and your
partner quote unquote responds this way
then that means they pass the
test now it's bad enough to bother your
boyfriend or husband about a bird but to
do it as a test so it's not even sincere
this is not a sincere bid for connection
it is manipulation it's that's what it
is it's a test and I can tell you this
if I get the sense that I'm being tested
I'm not playing
along I'm not I'm not doing that now
fortunately my wife doesn't play those
games which is good because I would
never play them and so this is a lot of
the advice you get there's all about no
don't te this this is not how to this is
not how you form or maintain a
meaningful relationship you don't do it
by testing okay this you're in a
relationship with them they're they're
not your student you're not you're not
giv them pop quizzes all the
time uh so the bird test the bird test
fails the moment you conduct it I think
is the point if You' like to see what
else I have to say you can access my
full show by going to dailywire.com or
by going to the Matt wall Show Twitter
page hope to see you there godp speed